When the learner is ready
the teacher will appear.
And when the learner no longer needs the
teacher, the teacher will be killed by
somebody and then you have to go off and
learn Kung Fu.
>> I think you're actually
taking the plot of Kung Fu.
[LAUGH]
>> I am, I am.
>> Okay.
>> Well anyway I'd like
to think Jordan Pollock for this.
I really love this example.
I was really the first example of kind
of mechanism design that really sort
of hit home for me.
>> Thanks.
And it seems relevant to this kind of
online teaching scenario
that we're in right now.
>> Yeah, I mean it's not enough for,
I mean I know I'm sure some people
taking this class have
actually done peer grading.
And there is always this question of
why won't everyone just give everybody
good grades.
You have to construct something so
that that doesn't happen.
>> Good.
>> Okay, so, I'm going to give
you one more example, I think.
And then I think maybe we'll
sort of cover the space enough.
What do you think of that?
>> That would be great.
>> Okay.